we're gonna begin with this of course
the first public hearing in the house
and Pietschmann inquiry against
President Trump is fast approaching in
just a short time lawmakers witnesses
and the public will pack this room for
the hearing President Trump as you know
is accused of withholding military aid
to Ukraine in exchange for Ukraine
investigating the Democrats this morning
we'll hear from Bill Taylor the top US
diplomat in Ukraine he has testified in
private that US aid was tied to Ukraine
investigating the president's political
foes Taylor will be joined by Deputy
Assistant Secretary of State George Kent
his closed-door testimony backed up
Taylor's claim of a quid pro quo the
hearings will continue on Friday with
former US ambassador to Ukraine Murray
Ivanovich she has testified that she
believed Rudy Guiliani the president's
personal attorney worked to have her
removed because she opposed any
investigations by Ukraine president
Trump denies he did anything wrong in
his dealings with Ukraine at all 60
minutes correspondent John Dickerson is
here to help put today's historic events
in context John good morning Anthony
bill Taylor George Kent Murray
Ivanovitch they're not household names
why does the house begin here you know I
wonder that's a good point it's in part
because they're not household names they
are the Democrats hope just the facts
ma'am witnesses they are people are
going to lay out and kind of tick the
box on that original whistleblower
report which alleged a certain number of
things and they will the Democrats hope
check off those boxes Democrats also
hope to build a structure so that people
understand additional facts that come in
in other words a story that they will
try and lay out and say these facts fit
along this storyline Republicans will
try to do two things
unpick the checks from those boxes and
also build their own narrative and say
everything you additionally hear fits
into our narrative not the Democrats
narrative you know this all started with
the whistleblower and the administration
keeps calling for the whistleblower to
come forward to be brought forward do we
really need the whistleblower now that
you've had apparently so many people
corporated the story
well the whistleblowers said person X
started yeah person x y&z and it's
important to know that the whistleblower
started this all because the
whistleblower followed the traditional
channels what happened here at basic in
the center of this is a number of people
who are used to having
operate one way saw things out bring
another way and use the channels to try
to figure out what was going on the
question of the whistleblower did the
whistleblower say things that are true
or not true well now you have the people
who actually did and said and believe
those things testifying so they are
closer to the truth of things than the
whistleblower was Republicans of course
want to focus on the whistleblower
because they want to undermine the facts
of the case that's not a you know that's
not a surprise strategy we've seen that
a loss speaking of non-household names
the format is going to be a little
different today as we understand it it's
not gonna be lawmakers asking a lot of
the questions but rather lawyers working
for those lawmakers asking the questions
why the effort is to try to get a to the
facts build the facts of this case to
take some of the drama out of this make
it a you know Democrats are on trial
here too they have to run they've been
talking about norms being shredded in
American life well they have a chance to
maintain the norms of how you go through
the facts of the case present them for
the American people and then get out of
the way they can't be seen as people who
have got a huge thumb on the scale and
one of the ways you do that is through
running a process that is as clean as
possible in terms of just laying out the
facts of the case and letting the people
there were Republicans planning to
defend the president and you heard them
complaining about the process to begin
where they were complaining they didn't
they weren't getting witnesses they now
have three so how do where do they go in
here well basically what they want to do
is undermine the process they want to
attack the facts where they can and if
they can't attack the facts where where
they can they want to undermine the
process and say but there's a challenge
for Republicans because you're getting
different kinds of responses one person
says what the president said on the
phone call and his policy there's
nothing wrong with it other people say
well it's wrong but it's not impeachable
well those are two odd things one person
says it had nothing to do with the
Biden's other people say let's call the
Biden's as witnesses if you can't get
your story straight after a month that
creates some possible tensions you know
so that they'll have to work out as
multiple people are shooting at this
information including from the White
House well there were also apparently
some concerns within Republicans that if
you say it's bad but not impeachable
there's a slippery slope there that you
could you could tripping and end up down
at of each of all well right because
when you say it's bad but not in people
you're signing up for a whole other
group of things because the president
said I didn't do anything wrong so if
you believe he did do something wrong
and he says he didn't do anything wrong
then implicit in your belief is that
he's now lying well so what happens when
the president
is that bad but not impeachable and then
there all these things being done to
defend the president are those bad but
not impeachable you get into what kind
of a long list if you take that bad but
not in P chable position we were always
raised all of us raised lying is not
good under any circumstances but let's
talk about Hillary Clinton
you know she's raising some eyebrows
because of something she said on the BBC
yesterday for those of you who haven't
heard we'll play that first then get
John's reaction look I as I say never
never never say never and I I will
certainly tell you I'm under enormous
pressure from many many many people to
think about it but as of this moment
sitting here and this studio talking to
you that is absolutely not in my plans
but she is letting us know that she is
under enormous pressure what do you make
of her putting that out there
I mean if you don't want to run you say
I'm not running yeah you don't say that
second sentence so it you know
traditionally the way to respire I
haven't talked to her Clinton or her
people so but traditionally what that
make you would make you think if
somebody wants to her wants to say out
loud Hillary Clinton believes quickly
John what does it say - you've got Deval
Patrick Bloomberg and Hillary now
talking about running yeah I mean polls
show the Democrats are happy with the
field but what it says is that a lot of
people who have money and a lot of
people who think hey I can be President
which is a huge group of people think
well I can throw my hat in the ring so
it means that the race is unstable but
races are always unstable at this point
so I Wilson CBS News we'll bring you a
complete coverage of the first public
hearing isn't the impeachment inquiry we
expect this morning session to begin at
10:00 9:00 central Norah O'Donnell will
anchor special reports from Washington
this morning and on Friday here on CBS
you can also find continuous coverage on
our streaming network cbsn download the
free CBS News app on your mobile or
connected device